welcome to this video again the eye and
let's see double fianchetto yeah not
that quick I need to react to poor
museum okay so d 5 or d6 yeah both are
very much possible yeah you will get a
symmetrical English position now um yeah
Bishop takes or queen takes Bishop takes
is also interesting and then Knight c3
why not we should solve the voice also
and that's not such a great place for
the Queen really yeah I can take now
here and then 95 which gives them a
pretty pretty awful structure check it's
even hard to to keep the d6 porn
route du monde qui know yeah i have c 5
as well is it a maturing much what rook
probably not be five i have c 5 just in
case if this is any go into play I mean
I can okay he wants probably yeah but I
can't push it him I can just push to c5
if he now trades and he doesn't um if he
would have traded played be five okay
before he s is you put a 3 queen bee for
might be might be a one idea maybe just
just go back and see what he's doing
next I'd like to get the Queen on the
long diagonal to get this temple on the
porn yeah like at this I Wade Quinn be
too no no no Bishop c4 their screen
deform winning a piece so that's not not
a problem and I want this temple on the
i'm on the porn you have 24 quindi fires
which is better than rock t4 ok maybe
it's the same i don't know but this
definitely wins apiece
black resigns yeah this this happens
sometimes that they run right into this
this Bishop takes f6 idea with which is
basically winning if you want the only I
mean II takes f is maybe a bit tougher
but check this is this is rather rather
simple from why'd you just pile up on
those those pawns and those weaknesses
with the dominating Queen and like this
is not coming back to that you will lose
opponent and really are an oval shape
can even argue that maybe Queen f4
intending rook t6 is better yeah you
should hear he just he just should not
play Queen c7 Queen a five maybe this is
kind of movies is ok so it's also a bit
more bit more active one point is that
if I now want to play this he has the
not this he has a five and this is a
huge problem so I cannot play Knight c3
easily you have to play another moose
different Quincy 122 whatever and then
it's just a normal game where black has
no particular problems yeah okay thanks
for watching